so let's get the obvious out of the way
I have braces because I thought that you
know what could possibly be sexier than
a 27 year old man with braces I have
developed a problem with my jaw over the
years it was a small click it eventually
became something worse and the doctor
said you're gonna have to get that fixed
and now I have braces before I talk
about Star Wars which I really want to
do I do have braces I just got them like
three days ago I've been experiencing
excruciating pain these things suck and
I'm just getting used to them and I
really hope you guys bear with me as I
get used to them my wife thinks it's
adorable when I mess up on a word I want
to punch myself in the face it's tough
but it's almost like a nerd rite of
passage like I have to have braces at
some point so I can officially call
myself a nerd the top row or the clear
kind the bottom row are the silver kind
my dad calls it the grill because my
dad's you know he's like that and I was
like wow
you called it a grill dad why'd you call
it a grill why why'd you call it that so
please bear with me over the next few
weeks as I figure out how to talk with
these on I hope you guys understand that
it's tough right now I was in
excruciating pain earlier and right now
it feels okay I took a couple excedrin
and that's really helping but what also
helped was I saw the teaser trailer for
rogue one and oh my god it looks
incredible let's talk about this I
really didn't know what to expect going
into this trailer and I was very pleased
to see that it was a full fledged
trailer it was actually a trailer with
character moments and dialogue it wasn't
just like the different shots that the
original force awakens teaser showed it
was actually a trailer with things to
look at and a story to behold now we
knew what the story was going to be
about so that's probably one of the
reasons why less secrets are being held
but there's still a lot of really cool
things in this trailer all new
from the age of 15 reckless aggressive
and undisciplined this is a rebellion
isn't it
IRA Belle she's talking somebody who
really resembles Mon Mothma I'm assuming
that is her because you know
many Bothans died to bring us this
information the thing that immediately
struck me about this trailer was the
look it looks exactly like 1977 Star
Wars every other shot I was just like oh
my god there's too much to focus on this
is also beautiful the CG does not look
like CG it actually looks like the old
models blew me away so pleased with the
way this looks it looks like a war film
which is really crazy because we've had
Star Wars movies for a long time and
none of them have really felt like war
films this look kind of like Saving
Private Ryan
now Darth Vader is rumored to be in this
movie there is one shot of a cloaked man
there are two Emperor's guards in this
room this guy could be the Emperor but I
highly doubt it that could actually be
Vader for a few different reasons for
one he drops to his knees
the Emperor is subservient to no one so
I'm assuming that's not the Emperor
so is that Vader outside of his costume
could that mean we might have Hayden
Christensen you know I wouldn't hate
that I wouldn't hate that to be honest
if it was minimal if it was just every
once in a while if it was you know just
lay it it wasn't written by George Lucas
which is not so yay I am so pleased with
the look of this trailer with the way
the whole film looks the CG looks
amazing the characters look great for us
Whitaker looks great the action looks
great it just looks like the Star Wars
movie I want to see this trailer looks
darker than I expected it looks more
like a war film it looks more gritty I
am so pumped for this movie what did you
guys think of the road one trailer
please once again bear with me as I cat
each of these braces I am totally ready
I am Sean Bean bracing myself for jokes
about braces I don't give a shit though
because my health is important to me
basically over the years my teeth in the
back crowded to the point where this
part of my job began to click and it got
really bad to the poor
a word was becoming slightly painful and
the orthodontist said if you don't fix
that it could be a really serious
problem when you're older so I got
braces
he's estimating about a year but he gave
me this thing called Axela dent it's
like this thing I bite down on and it
does like sensory pulses to my teeth and
supposed to speed up the process plus
everyone who's ever had braces has told
me that after like a week it gets easier
and you get used to talking right now
I'm amazed I'm not feeling pain because
the past three days we're absolutely
excruciating that excedrin is helping
though so bear with me please as I adapt
to having braces trust me I don't want
them I don't but I know my health is
important and I severely do not want to
have like my entire right side of my jaw
pop off one day which could actually
happen if I didn't get this fixed so
that's what I got to do health is
important guys also hats off to any of
my subscribers who have braces I feel
you I really do I'm gonna have a review
for hardcore Henry this weekend but
there's not going to be a hilarious 'ti
this Sunday because I just it hurts to
talk right now to be honest guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes